welcome you have been chosen to spend 50  days in the immaculate room and will win  5 million by completing the task  enjoy your stay in the immaculate  rome oh  it's like we're in a dream it's a second  chance for us isn't it we should just be  grateful  that's it  smells like  nothing  so i guess this would be the master  bedroom very  white  this is your wake-up call  why do you think he's doing all this  professor why him all anyone knows about  him is he's got more money than god and  that he's intrigued by the human  condition  it is midday i hate that clock  it actually went backwards  mikey  michael  how to get in here  they're just messing with us right  i really can take a treat  hey it's like what happens in here then  she just walked out  i did not  know this is gonna be fun  good night  i don't think i can do this anymore this  is all a little ridiculous what's going  on here not everyone's so easily  manipulated  love is the only real thing about you  enjoy your stay  you